en directo a América de France 24
hablamos de economía y por ello me
acompañan el estudio mi compañero Jorge
Hurtado Jorge bienvenido vamos a iniciar
con la noticia que movió los mercados la
pausa en la subida de los tipos de
interés en Estados Unidos bueno esta
pausa del Banco Central estadounidense
se da tras 15 meses de subidas de los
tipos de interés pero advirtieron que el
endurecimiento volvería a futuro para
tratar de apaciguar la inflación por
ahora los tipos se mantendrán entre el
5% al
5,25%, los responsables monetarios
Estados Unidos están de acuerdo en que
es necesario un mayor endurecimiento
para bajar la inflación esto se
materializaría en dos subidas
adicionales de tipos de interés de un
cuarto de punto o una subida de medio
punto antes de finales de año para los
expertos esta pausa ha sido prudente y
aunque la inflación subyacente este dato
que excluye los precios de la energía y
los alimentos se mantiene por encima del
objetivo ya hay mejoras en los últimos
meses aquí los comentarios el presidente
de la reserva Federal Durante los
últimos meses justo hace un año Powell
repetía que la inflación sería
transitoria y por eso fue bastante
criticado por actuar según expertos algo
tarde a la ola de la inflación a
principios de este año los mercados
bursátiles y la renta fija volvieron o
vivieron un momento crítico cuando
cuatro bancos regionales colapsaron por
los efectos de la subida de los tipos de
interés pese a esto el mercado laboral
se ha mantenido Sólido y la tasa de
inflación General continúa siendo más
del doble del objetivo del 2% fijado por
la reserva federal y esto supone que
este episodio económico aún no termina
para el Banco Central Jorge Paul también
brindó su previsión de crecimiento de
Estados Unidos bueno la Fed mejora
espera una mejora en sus previsiones
económicas del 2023 pero reduce las de
2024 hay dos datos importantes ahí la
previsión de crecimiento para este año
en Estados Unidos subió al 1% frente al
0,4% previsto en marzo pasado y rebajó
levemente al 3,2% su pronóstico de
inflación General desde el anterior
3,3%, esto Dijo Jerome Power el
presidente de la Fed
los participantes en el comité esperan
en general que continúe un crecimiento
moderado en nuestro resumen de
proyecciones económicas la proyección
mediana sitúa el crecimiento del pib
Real en el 1,0 por ciento este año y en
el 1,1 el próximo
vamos con Los indicadores económicos de
esta jornada bueno la bolsa de Nueva
York cerró mixto a pesar de la decisión
de la reserva Federal de no subir los
tipos de interés en esta ocasión en
Europa las acciones subieron apoyadas
por los bancos y las mineras y en
América Latina el índice es ampimer
balde Argentina cerró con una caída del
0,83% hasta los
3.378.695 puntos Bueno aquí hay una
noticia que nos interesa a todos no a
todos los que nos guste la tecnología y
a los que no les guste también porque el
parlamento europeo aprobó su posición
final sobre la ley de Inteligencia
artificial Bueno ese texto es la base de
una futura ley que regulará sistemas de
Inteligencia artificial como el famoso
chat gppy la normativa busca regular los
productos o los servicios que utilicen
Inteligencia artificial regularía la
Inteligencia artificial en función del
nivel de riesgo cuanto mayor sea el
riesgo para los derechos o la salud de
las personas mayores Serán las
obligaciones de las empresas de
tecnología se contemplan multas de hasta
30 millones de euros o el 6% de los
ingresos globales anuales de una empresa
dedicada a este sector se prohibirá a la
vigilancia biométrica el reconocimiento
de emociones o la vigilancia predictiva
para identificar posibles actividades
delictivas un punto novedoso Valentina
de esta ley es que obligará a los
sistemas de Inteligencia artificial
generativa como el chat de pity o el
dailing que hoy son capaces de producir
texto imágenes vídeo código o audio como
las fotos del papa con un look bastante
juvenil que informen si este material
fue generado por una máquina o por un
humano los legisladores dicen que es un
proyecto de ley histórico y niegan que
La regulación vaya a perjudicar la
innovación en este sector usted ya probó
estas aplicaciones el chat y cómo le fue
No no ha traído información de chat no
sin duda Sí pero es muy bueno bueno a
propósito de este tema Jorge el
presidente francés Emmanuel macronce
pronunció bueno quiere que Francia se
convierta en líder de Inteligencia
artificial así lo dijo durante su
intervención en vivatec en París que es
una de las mayores ferias tecnológicas
de Europa el presidente anunció que su
país invertirá 500 millones de euros
adicionales en Inteligencia artificial
para competir con los desarrollos de
Estados Unidos y otras potencias en el
mismo evento estará elon musk el día
viernes donde hablará de neverlink una
de sus empresas que prueba en humanos
una tecnología que utiliza implantes
para conectar los cerebros humanos con
computadoras macron compartió escenario
con los fundadores de varias startup
francesas entre ellas Mister Ey que
recaudó 105 millones de euros un récord
para una empresa francesa dedicada a la
inteligencia Inteligencia artificial y
vamos a cerrar con la cifra del día 15
dólares mensuales Ese es el costo por
suscripción en la plataforma onlyfans
del clavadista mexicano Diego ballesa el
atleta es uno de los varios mexicanos
afectados por una disputa entre y la
federación de deportes acuáticos de
México que desde hace enero hace que la
Comisión Nacional del deporte mexicana
dejará de financiar la preparación de
estos deportistas ahora ellos se las
ingenian para recaudar fondos y
participar en los Juegos Olímpicos de
París en 2024 el atleta ofrece paquetes
trimestrales por 40 dólares y busca
reponer unos 1700 dólares mensuales que
recibía como parte de una beca
gubernamental pues alternativas bastante
ingeniosos Jorge usted muchas gracias
Nos vemos en la próxima sí señor
quédense con nosotros que ya vamos con
directo a
[Música]